The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today is
the human power lab.
And we're going to start
with a lab safety tour
that Gwyn is going to run.
This is Gwyn Jones,
who's a D lab instructor.
He's teaching D lab design
with a couple of other people
this semester and has a
lot of shop experience
and a good person to have
as a resource around.
So he'll do the safety tour.
Once you have the safety
tour, then you guys
are free to use the
lab after hours,
which is a nice resource.
And then after that, we're
going to split up into teams,
try to divide the class evenly.
And I think we're at
about 16 students, so five
or six students per team.
And each group is going
to do a different thing.
And then we're going
to switch twice,
so that everyone
does everything.
So the three options
are machining with Gwyn
in the D lab lab,
which I think is 102--
but that might be a lie--
water carrying, which will
start up here with me,
and water pumping, which will
be outside in the driveway,
outside the D lab.
So make sure you know where
your coats are if you're not
wearing a sweater.
Because it's a
little chilly out.
And then we'll rotate.
And hopefully, we'll get
done a little early today,
but not a ton early.
So we'll see.
There's five of you.
So one person is going
to be the spotter,
because some of these
water carrying methods
are rather challenging.
Because the tour that you're
going to do four times,
five, one is a spotter,
to do all the attempts,
you're going to go down
this hall, down the stairs,
outside, cross the street,
and then come back.
And so that's to experience
flat surface, nice and easy,
stairs, more or less easy
depending on the method,
and then some rough terrain.
So that's the plan.
And the methods are
traditional American style,
a method that's common primarily
for women all over the world.
And I may need help
to get this up.
Yeah, I'm totally going to
need help to get this up.
So you just work
to get it centered.
And then hypothetically, you
can do this with no hands.
I've yet to meet any D
labber who can do that.
But you meet plenty
of people who can
in developing countries.
But try to get to one
hand when you're doing it.
And if you see
people who have been
doing this their whole
lives, not only--
Oh, that was really bad.
Good thing we have two.
Not only can they
do it with no hands.
But your head has a
point in the middle.
So they'll start on one side.
And then when they get
tired, they just go like that
and switch to the other side.
And it works, which I
don't know how you do that.
So that's two methods.
Number three is called
a temp line, which
is used in many developing
countries as well,
often in the same places
they do head carries.
And so for this one, it
goes on your forehead.
And it uses your neck.
And you play with it to get
it comfortable on your neck.
In areas where this
is really common
and people are carrying one to
two times their body weight,
you see most of their
foreheads have ridges.
Because it just digs in,
because you're carrying
from a pretty young age.
And then the last method
is called the Q drum, which
you can see here, which
was invented-- actually,
there's two different
groups that do it.
One is the Q drum.
One is the hippo roller.
And the idea is to help kids
carry water very far distances.
So a lot of people are carrying
water many miles, or at least
a mile, every single day.
They're usually kids
and women doing it.
And so we're not even going
to come close to a mile.
And we're generally carrying
less water than they are.
And we ate a much
better breakfast
and got a much better rest
and are in much better health.
So it will be a little
annoying, but not as annoying
as it would be if
this was your life.
So it's a little snapshot.
So come on around.
Let's get started.
That actually looks pretty good.
Let it go down step by step.
AUDIENCE: The crown on beach.
Hi, everyone.
Oh, there's a [INAUDIBLE]
you can see it.
PROFESSOR: What we kind of want
the point of this module to be
is for you to understand how
much power we can generate
with your arms versus legs.
And so this is a pump
that uses your legs.
And that's a pump
that uses your arms.
Everyone here is going
to use both pumps to try
to fill the bucket and see how
much power you can generate.
This pump was a redesign on
a plastic injection molded
pump that was done by the
full grout eye project
by Josh Brandes.
And he made the entire
thing out of cement.
It's the way more applicable
for the developing world.
So you can measure power by
pressure times volumetric flow.
So we're measuring
volumetric flow
by how quickly we can fill a
five gallon bucket with water.
And the way we're
measuring pressure
is we're going to use
the hydrostatic pressure
equation, which is RHO GH.
And so we're going to
measure the height that we're
pumping the water to and
then just multiply it
by the density of
water and gravity.
OK, you ready?
AUDIENCE: Go for it.
PROFESSOR: Go.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's like stuck.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe take it
out of the water, like--
There you go.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, this is tiring.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's a workout.
AUDIENCE: That's good.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: 2:45.
Oh, what happens is when
water pushes down on--
water gets pushed
down this way, it
pushes the marble against that
inner lip and creates a seal.
And then on the top
you have a PVC pipe
that has either
a nail through it
or is bent to close
it in some way.
So that when water
gets pushed this way,
it pushes against this lip.
And then water can
flow around the marble.
And so it creates
a one way valve.
And it's actually a
really good one way valve.
And the cool thing about it
is it gets better with time,
because the plastic bends around
to the shape of the marble,
instead of other one way valves,
which get much worse with time.
AUDIENCE: Is everything set up?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
As long as you have
enough clearance here.